for the audience who doesn't know
who you are and what you're doing what
clear view ai is once you take a minute
and give them a background on clearview
ai sure uh so the way i like to describe
clearview ai it's like a google for
faces so it's a search engine but
instead of putting in uh words when you
type someone's name or any kind of
information you upload a photo of
someone's face and everything in
the database that you find is publicly
available so the three biggest
misperceptions about clearview ai in
terms of what it does one is it searches
private data none of the information
that we're searching is private it's all
publicly available anything you can find
in a google search the second thing is
that it's a real time surveillance right
so
this is actually used after the fact so
after a crime has been committed
then you will run a photo through the
search engine and a lot of controls in
place
that ensure that law enforcement are
using it you know for after the fact
investigations and the third you know
misconception is
that
people would take a photo do a match and
make an arrest there's a lot more that
goes into the technology and also the
process that uh law enforcement use it
for uh before they make any kind of
arrest or uh search warrant or anything
like that
so you can see how that may concern some
people like the absolutely yeah so what
what are some of the common concerns
you're seeing and the pushback from the
app because you were you had you got to
see some assists from who let me see
google youtube uh linkedin and there was
one other one that put a vimeo i think
put a cease and desist on you but that's
just a cease and desist
stop doing what you're doing uh
australia even said i can read what
australia said and then italy put the
fine why why are companies like google
linkedin
vimeo youtube why is australia why is
italy why are so many organizations
afraid of what clearview ai does
so it's an honor to be at the center of
the debate so i think what we created
was something actually new and hadn't
been done before and any new technology
from the printing press even the word
processor has controversy when it comes
out because people aren't sure what the
implications are going to be of it and
so our job is to really kind of educate
people on how it's really used and all
that kind of stuff and when it comes to
um you know the people who are the
detractors uh we've seen a lot of them
move over uh to our side over time but
with major events like the capital riots
where we're instrumental in helping id
people and now in the situation in
ukraine but fundamentally like you said
a lot of people who use our technology
in law enforcement they really love it
and they say they can't do without it so
some of these agencies especially
federal ones solving crimes against
children they've said without clear of
uai there are so many cases of child
molesters that would have never been
caught or children who wouldn't have
been saved so i'd rather live in a world
where our customers really love us and
they would actually do so much for us
and we really love them as well and hear
those kind of stories and be you know
somewhat misunderstood by the rest as
opposed to the opposite if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you